about the bad news coming as far as
debenhams is concerned
um confirmed it's winding down
operations after rescue talks with jd
sports collapse ian
with more for us now and as we're saying
in no doubt
link to what's happening with arcadia
there is a connection certainly yes
because around uh
one twentieth of uh deb's revenues come
from arcadia concessions within
the business but i think this is
probably a retail collapse on an of
even greater magnitude than that of
arcadia
debenhams employs something like 14 000
people so slightly more
than uh have been affected by the news
that arcadia has gone into
administration
i the reason i say it's of a bigger
order is because of course it's
perfectly possible that parts of arcadia
may be sold and some jobs
will be saved that is not going to be
the case with debenhams and also bear in
mind k
this is a far far older and more
established business
even than arcadia which of course uh
traces parts of it tracer
their origins back to uh just after the
first world war well
debenhams traces its history back to
1778 when it started out
selling uh drapery in wigmore street in
london's west end
it was bought by william debenham in
1813
and it was one of the big mainstays of
uk retailing in the victorian age one of
the things that really
got it going was the fact that uh the
victorian etiquette for uh going into
mourning and people uh dressing
the same way after a relative had died
well debenhams made big out of that
that's a great great storage history and
it looks like very sadly it's going to
come to an end 124 stores closing